magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code Pacman welcome to
the show everybody I said yesterday
which was our first show of the year and
the first show of the week that as soon
as we had kind of catch-up data uh from
the holiday weekend about covid we would
look at the numbers and that it's
expected that the numbers are off the
wall shocking appalling numbers and
indeed they are when it comes to cases
the numbers are appallingly bad when it
comes to testing in terms of the
difficulty of getting a test and the
extremely high positivity rate of tests
showing how incredibly widespread this
Omicron variant is but we continue to
see death numbers that while well they
are still tragic are making us hopeful
that this Omicron variant is going to
burn through the population
in maybe the next four to six weeks
without a proportionately uh High death
toll and then go now what happens after
that there are three or four different
perspectives which we will eventually
talk about but let's take a look at the
numbers and they are just incredible how
contagious this thing is is really
really hard to believe in the United
States now uh just a a vertical increase
and we'll look at the exact numbers if
you look at the day by day
days of nearly six consecutive days of
nearly 600 000 cases in a single day and
a lot of the backlog data is still being
cataloged but these are incredible
numbers at this point if we have 500 000
cases a day that we know about we would
expect that the real number of
infections is between 1 million and 1.5
million actual infections a day to
account for home tests that don't show
up in these data and to account for
people who never get tested twenty
percent positivity rates in many states
and big cities if we look over at uh
this is this is death let's not go there
yet if we look at Global cases we see
that Global cases are now reaching 2
million cases a day that we know about
that we know about and with the
difficulty of tax testing that also
exists in many other countries some
countries have great testing some
countries don't we can also safely
estimate the real number of infections
if officially it's two million cases a
day there's probably between four and
six million infections per day or even
more if you think about just the U.S
numbers actually but before we get to
that article from CNBC
U.S reports over one million new daily
coveted cases the U.S has reported a
record single day number of coveted
cases with more than a million new
infections a total of 1.02 million new
cases were reported Monday yesterday per
Johns Hopkins University as the highly
infectious Omicron variant continues to
spread throughout the country and Beyond
the U.S also has the highest seven day
average of new daily cases in any
country tracked by Johns Hopkins
um
this brings the total confirmed cases to
56 million over 827 000 deaths now the
record single day total may be due in
part to delayed reporting from the
holiday weekend so that's what's really
important to look at when you might be
saying David wait so if if a million
were reported yesterday why does a
worldometer say that it was only 426 000
a million were reported yesterday some
were from January 3rd some were from
January 2nd somewhere from January 1st
and December 31st so we're rapidly
getting up there for a moment
let's imagine that the real number of
cases just to make the math easy is 1.6
million a day why do I pick 1.6 million
well the US has a population of about
330 million so 1.6 million 1.65 million
would be exactly half of one percent per
day if you start doing the math and you
think about well some people if you have
three shots of moderna or Pfizer
um you're about 75 percent protected
from symptomatic infections so when we
think about the population if there's
some people who have recovered from
prior covid and have protection some
protection from Omicron it's diminished
but some protection from Ahmed crime you
have some people then who even if
exposed aren't going to get it you then
have people who have three shots which
gives you some significant protection
against dominicron although vaccinated
people are getting this all over the
place we know that so you've got that
population and then if every two days
one percent of the population is getting
it you start doing the math
30 days of this High case rate is going
to have most of the country exposed
many will get it many will be
asymptomatic some will be exposed and
fighted off thanks to vaccination or
prior immunity in 30 days
there can only be one path for Omicron
and it's down very quickly and we're
seeing that in South Africa now could
there be another variant of course could
there be all sorts of different things
of course but when you have something
this contagious where every two days one
percent of your population is getting it
in a country this big and you have some
immunity in the population and you have
some vaccine protection in the
population
at some point something has to break and
so the the cautious optimism is that
this will get us much closer to the end
of the pandemic phase what about deaths
the good news continues to be
that deaths are not spiking the Omicron
spike in cases started right around
Thanksgiving and while there has been an
increase in deaths the average daily
going from about 900 up to about 12
1300.
um cases are dramatically higher and the
deaths are not yet spiking and it's been
a while we're into five weeks now in
South Africa Omicron led to a case
increase of
150 x a day
150 times increase in cases and deaths
only doubled now South Africa is
different in a lot of ways much younger
population than the us as I said
yesterday
etc etc but the fact that deaths are not
spiking in proportion with cases is very
good globally deaths continue to decline
at the start of the um the Omicron
uh spread
Global deaths were at about 7 000 a day
and now global deaths are under six
thousand a day we're cautious we're
cautious but this is
reason to be cautiously optimistic one
last thing on this uh the CDC has
shortened the waiting period for Pfizer
covet boosters to five months remember
the CDC had said get your third dose at
least six months after your second dose
now the CDC is saying five months and uh
It is believed that part of the reason
is that that third dose is so much more
effective at preventing symptomatic
illness from Omicron that the
recommendation is changing so that is a
very good thing these are the numbers as
we have them right now we're going to
continue to follow them it's both
appalling the difficulty of getting
tests
uh and the number of cases it also is
assigned to say wow if cases are this
high and we're not seeing death Spike
dramatically that's a really really good
sign we will follow the science
um one of the really sick things that's
happening in the United States is that
instead of everybody coming together
to get beyond the pandemic to encourage
people to hey if you have a reason to go
and get tested go and get tested and
let's support testing and let's grow the
number of places where you can get
tested there are people harassing those
going and getting a coveted test I'm
going to play a clip for you in a moment
of anti-vaxxers coveted truthers and
other types of conspiracists in New York
City yelling conspiracy theories at
people who are trying to get coveted
tests at one of these Corner pop-up
clinics now we don't know exactly when
the clip was filmed the the clip was
recently released but from the way
people are dressed it doesn't seem like
it's that cold in New York City now at
the same time a couple days ago it was
in the mid 50s in New York city so this
may be very recent or maybe a little bit
older we don't know
but let's take a look at the video and
what you're going to hear if you're just
listening is people yelling conspiracy
theories and berating people getting
tested you get tested why so you know if
you should stay home and not give this
thing to other people it's a good thing
to do and here are anti-vaxxers and
conspiracists attacking those getting
tested shut it down these are faulty
test yeah this is what's creating all
these fake numbers and creating more
fears fake PCR tests are creating fake
numbers which are creating fear I'll
address this substantively in a moment
by the way
are you guys
[Music]
do you guys
inventor that PCR tests
always
said that the BCR test is not accurate
at all you guys
[Music]
person that invented your test you guys
listen to the person that invented the
PCR test they don't even know wow they
don't know who Dr Karen what it was they
don't know who was this is
getting tested leads to propaganda
[Applause]
I wonder where all those bajillion codes
so it came from a fake task
getting a medical procedure on a dirty
rat infested Manhattan street corner
getting a medical procedure
Carrie Mullis Carrie Mullis Carrie moles
Kerry Mullis Carrie Mullis Carrie
Mullins PCR or maker Carrie males Carrie
Mullins all right so you get the idea
obviously police should be called in
these situations
um and there's a bunch of different
things to talk about first of all if you
believe in my body my choice leave
people who want to get a test alone
don't harass them let them get a test
you don't nobody's forcing you to get a
test what happened to my body my choice
but let's address substantly but
substantively what they're talking about
because I keep getting emails about this
as well saying the inventor of PCR said
the PCR test isn't accurate let me
explain to you exactly what is the the
truth about this uh because it has been
misstated and misstated and misstated a
PCR test measures the presence of a
certain viral proteins okay
it is true that I could imagine that
someone coughs on me who has coveted
okay I breathe in some viral proteins
and they are now in my nose
I get swabbed the swab is tested and
it's positive for viral proteins but
I'm triple vaccinated
my body could be fighting off those
viral particles and the viral particles
thank goodness don't replicate and I
don't get an infection
certainly it's conceivable that if you
swab me at the exact moment where those
viral particles that someone coughed on
me are in my throat that I get a
positive test and I never get sick
because my body fights it off that's
possible what the PCR test measures
is the presence of that virus in the
body it can't definitively tell you are
you sick with covid do you have an
active contagious infection or did you
have just enough viral particles in your
system to trigger a positive test and
then you didn't actually get sick that's
true
generally speaking the timing of that
specific situation I mentioned is very
very rare and it doesn't mean that PCR
tests shouldn't be used can't be used
aren't of diagnostic value it is true it
is true that you could have the presence
of virus and not be actively infected
it's a very small portion of people
uh and it's not really relevant to
testing strategy in the way that these
people want it to be now unfortunately
this anti-testing stuff is actually
spreading in Florida Florida has a
pretty wacky surge in general Joseph
ladapo he says it's time to unwind this
testing psychology prioritized by the
federal government you don't need to go
and get there's he's saying do less
testing don't be so worried about going
and testing here he is we're going to be
working to unwind the sort of testing
psychology right that our federal
leadership has managed to unfortunately
get much most of the country in over the
last two years right testing problem now
the federal government is making too
many people want to get tested let's
unwind it we don't need tests and we
don't need testing wow what a strategy
by the way have you seen Florida's
numbers we need to unwind this test
things sort of uh
um sort of planning and living one's
life around testing without it we're
going to be sort of stuck in the same
cycle so you know it's really time for
people to be living to uh you know to
make the decisions they want regarding
vaccination yeah to enjoy the fact that
many people have natural immunity there
you go uh
oh man meanwhile Florida you'll be told
Florida is doing great Florida
hospitalizations are up 200 percent even
if Omicron is indeed less severe on a
case-by-case percentage basis as we
believe it is Florida with a skewing
older population does see plus 200
percent in terms of hospitalization so a
lot of horrible backwards things going
on with something as benign
as testing and that does not bode
particularly well let me know what
you're seeing in your community find me
on Twitter at dpacman one of our
sponsors is Magic spoon breakfast cereal
sweet and tasty like the cereals I loved
as a kid but without the sugar or the
carbs every serving of magic spoon has
zero grams of sugar only four net carbs
140 calories and packed with 13 grams of
protein perfect if you're doing keto
perfect if you're doing low carb great
if you're just trying to reduce your
excess sugar intake and because it's
packed with protein it's great before or
after a workout magic spoon flavors
include cocoa fruity frosted peanut
butter blueberry and cinnamon They're
bringing back cookies and cream They're
bringing back Maple waffle you can build
your own variety box and try them all
magic spoon is so confident in the
product if you don't love it as much as
I do they will refund your money no
questions asked go to magicspoon.com
Pacman the link is underneath the this
video and you'll get five dollars off
when you use the promo code Pacman at
checkout as many of you know we've been
taking the real kind of systemic
authoritarian risk in the United States
much more seriously lately and when we
talked about the possibility of a repeat
in 2024 of what the Republican Party
under Trump attempted in 2020 it's no
laughing matter we also talked earlier
this week about the warning from three
retired military generals that if you
had the uh ranking upper echelon of the
military
supportive of something like what Donald
Trump tried to do in 2020 you could have
very different results because you could
have a military involved coup in the
United States there is now another new
commentary from a Canadian Professor who
is warning that the United States could
actually fall to a right-wing
dictatorship by 2030. this is a very
interesting article not very long I
encourage you to read it we're going to
link to it and it says that a Canadian
political science Professor has warned
that the U.S could be under a right-wing
dictatorship by the end of the decade
this is Thomas Homer Dixon founding
director of the Cascade Institute at
Royal Rhodes University in British
Columbia
he is urging Canada to safeguard itself
against the possible collapse of
American democracy he wrote In The Globe
and Mail by 2025 American democracy
could collapse causing extreme domestic
political instability including
widespread civil Violence by 2030 if not
sooner the country could be governed by
a right-wing dictatorship much of the
professor's hypothesis centers around
the idea of trump returning to the White
House in 2024 Trump is widely expected
to run for office again I don't know
about that
I don't know about that he's it's
considered that he may and Mr Homer
Dixon anticipates Republican held state
legislatures will refuse to accept a
Democratic presidential win that is a
concern and we've talked about that so
many times now this idea that they
wanted to push on Pence for January 6
2020 and we're almost at the one year
anniversary of that day the idea was
states that so I'll I'll break it down
from the beginning
before the election say you're worried
that there's going to be a lot of voter
fraud because of mail-in ballots
after the election when Joe Biden won a
bunch of these states they claim we
can't actually trust the results and
then the third part which they didn't do
they wanted Mike Pence to do what they
didn't do would have been Mike Pence or
whoever is vice president but it was
pence in 2020 at the time of the
certification of those electoral votes
of the acceptance of those electoral
votes rather the certification was on
December 14th or so January 6th was
we're going to tally these for pens to
say
we don't believe that these are genuine
results so instead of allowing the
Democratic electors from Arizona to vote
we are going to seat an alternate slate
of electors to vote for Trump that was
the idea the concern now is they had the
idea in 2020 but they didn't do it
that they're actually going to do it in
2024.
um Homer Dixon is a well-respected
scholar of violent conflict
he says Canada should be on guard
against the unfolding crisis in
Washington D.C spreading northward he
said quote a terrible storm is coming
from the south and Canada is woefully
unprepared over the past year we've
turned our attention inward distracted
by the challenges of covid
reconciliation and the accelerating
effects of climate change but he says
now we must focus on the Urgent problem
of what to do about the likely
unraveling of democracy in the U.S we
need to start by recognizing the
magnitude of the danger if Trump is
re-elected even under the more
optimistic scenarios the economic and
political risks to our country will be
innumerable some might view such
warnings as hyperbolic but the political
scientist is steadfast in his view that
a new Trump Administration with little
in the way of internal opposition could
seek to deliberately undermine its
northern neighbor Canada is worried and
we're worried about the same thing and
the crazy thing is that we sort of just
have to wait and see what happens and
what I mean by that is Trump was
impeached twice not convicted nothing
really came of it corruption in
government isn't changing for the better
in any real way we got a warning from
three retired generals yesterday that if
the military were on the side of what
Trump wanted to do they might actually
have been able to make it happen and it
could happen in 2024 and unfortunately
most Americans don't even realize what's
going on
um I want to play for you this is really
interesting this is a clip from Joe
Rogan talking to Jordan Peterson and it
applies to this they are talking about
covet guidelines this is the crazy thing
they're talking about covet guidelines
we're talking about actual
authoritarianism from a government and
even though what they are talking about
doesn't apply okay it this actually does
apply to what's going on right now just
don't understand how it gets to them and
actually they may not even have been
talking about covet here that they may
have been talking about
it's not even clear what they're talking
about they're not talking about trumpism
and authoritarianism of that sense but
it would apply when I think things get
to terrible places one tiny step at a
time you know if I encroach I if I
encroach on you and I'm sophisticated
about it I'm going to encroach two
millimeters I'm going to encroach right
to the point where you start start to
protest then I'm going to stop then I'm
going to wait
then you're gonna calm down then I'm
going to encroach again right to the
point where you protest then I'm going
to stop then I'm going to wait and I'm
just going to do that forever and before
you know it you're going to be back
three miles from where you started and
you'll have done it one step at a time
and then you'll go oh I understand Rogan
this is I this is from a little bit ago
but Rogan posted it yesterday
pretty obviously signaling that it's
about covet but it applies perfectly to
January 6th the coup attempt and what we
may be facing get here and the answer
was well
I pushed you a little farther than you
should have gone and you agreed and so
then I pushed you a little farther than
you should have gone again and you
agreed and if anybody's interested in
this sort of process and this is a
horrifying book if you want to read
about how this process works you can
read a book called Ordinary Men by
Robert Browning so it perfectly
perfectly perfectly applies to what we
are seeing now and it's not that people
necessarily accept but it's that not
enough is being done to stop it from
happening again and uh incredibly
relevant commentary from Jordan Peterson
not applied to what it should be applied
to a very big breaking news uh Donald
Trump Ivanka Trump and Donald Trump Jr
have been subpoenaed by the New York
attorney general
this is we are talking about Leticia
James who is a Democrat Leticia James
has been investigating uh the Trump
Organization for possible Financial
crimes and we have learned yesterday
that subpoenas have been issued for
Donald Trump Ivanka Trump and Donald
Trump Jr now what is that issue here as
a reminder is the oh what's the right
word I mean is it is it scamming is it
lying is it's the widely at this point
accepted allegation that we heard from
Michael Cohen and others that Donald
Trump would lie one way or the other the
Trump organization would deceive one way
or the other about the value of
properties in order to achieve whatever
goal they had so basically the way it
works is as follows imagine that you
have a building that's actually worth 25
million dollars just as an example let's
say you have a 25 million dollar
building
if you want to get a loan and you want a
35 million dollar loan when the bank
says what's your collateral you say I've
got this building that's worth 50
million now it's really only worth 25
but you say it's worth 50. so you can
safely give me a loan of 35 million
against it but when the tax authorities
come to you and they say hey this
building it's worth 25 million so you're
going to have to pay property tax on the
basis of a 25 million dollar value say
no no no no this building is only worth
10 million is this a crappy little
building and you argue that it is worth
less in order to reduce your tax
liability and that is of course fraud it
is fraud to to do that and that is one
of the elements that is being
investigated by the Attorney General
Leticia James they have previously
requested that Donald Trump appear
we have now learned that they have
issued a subpoena for Donald Trump and
two of his adult children to appear and
they have already announced their plans
to refuse ABC is reporting eldest
children won't comply with subpoenas
from New York attorney general
a Donald Trump Jr and Ivanka Trump are
now respondents in the civil case they
have refused to comply with subpoenas
issued by the New York State Attorney
General's office as it conducts a civil
investigation into the way the family
real estate business valued its holding
a dispute has arisen between the oag and
the individual Trump parties regarding
the subpoenas the document filed jointly
by New York attorney general Leticia
James and an attorney for the Trump
organization said Don Jr and Ivanka will
now be named as respondents in the
inquiry which parallels a criminal
investigation by the Manhattan District
Attorney's office as her investigation
into Financial dealing with the Trump
organization continues Attorney General
James is seeking interviews under oath
of Donald Trump trump Jr and Ivanka
despite numerous attempts to delay our
investigation by the Trump organization
we are confident that our questions will
be answered and the truth will be
uncovered because no one is above the
law Donald Trump Jr and Ivanka Trump
sought to quash the subpoenas Monday
evening in a motion
Alan feuderfoss the attorney
representing the Trump children
questioned the motives her office is
also involved in the criminal
investigation of trump he wrote the goal
of the subpoenas is all too clear she
seeks to circumvent the entire grand
jury process and nullify moving party's
most fundamental constitutional and
statutory rights by requesting they
provide non-immunized testimony to the
Office of the Attorney General when they
and the district attorney of New York
are jointly conducting a grand jury
investigation so there's a couple
different legal opinions here one legal
opinion is the ability of Congress to
enforce subpoenas is somewhat vague
but the ability here to enforce
subpoenas is uh unquestioned there is no
legal question as to the ability of the
enforce the ability to enforce these
subpoenas but at the same time they can
show up and invoke their Fifth Amendment
rights and
um there are some limitations to that
one lawyer I spoke to said you know you
can really only invoke your fifth
amendment rights when it is reasonable
to believe that speaking could actually
incriminate you that there are
circumstances where what you are being
asked about could not reasonably be
considered to incriminate you and thus
invoking your Fifth Amendment right
um would would not be okay here it
genuinely does seem that they may have
been involved in criminality and so the
likelihood that if they were pushed and
forced to respond to the subpoena and
provide testimony that they would invoke
their Fifth Amendment rights if you ask
10 different lawyers there's 10
different opinions about this and so
ultimately we have to wait and see but
much like all of the other things we've
seen so far this may also get no
traction but but
the fact that there were subpoenas is
certainly noteworthy and over the next
24 to 48 hours I mean we we may well
learn more about the fate of these
subpoenas some say the walls are closing
in
I still don't think Trump sees a day of
jail or prison I just don't see it I'm
not going to blow smoke in your nose or
up anywhere of yours I will have more
coverage of this on our Instagram which
you can find at David Pacman show leave
a comment there and let me know if you
think anything will come of this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
yesterday we talked about radical
republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green being banned from Twitter for her
fifth strike spreading disinformation
and I uh told you the details of it and
we mentioned you know when these things
happen it's of course correct but they
immediately turn it into I'm the victim
they immediately throw out their
principles of businesses should be
allowed to do what they want as long as
it's not illegal it's the same tired
routine and now unfortunately it's
scaling up even more because Marjorie
Taylor green has been suspended from
Facebook just hours after the Twitter
ban this one does not appear to be
permanent
um the congresswoman claimed data showed
the covid-19 vaccine was unsafe Marjorie
Taylor Greene the right-wing
congresswoman famous for her support of
conspiracy theories about the 2020
election coveted 19 and other issues has
been temporarily suspended from Facebook
hours after being banned permanently
from Twitter the Congress woman
confirmed her suspension in a telegram
post calling the company's decision
Beyond censorship of free speech sorry
Beyond censorship of speech her
suspension appeared to result
from the same post that got her a final
fifth strike from Twitter which led to
her accounts deactivation a post
claiming that vaccine injury and death
reports gathered by a reporting service
operated by the FDA proved that the
government was ignoring large numbers of
deaths resulting from the vaccine now
that's untrue of course in reality the
data used by the congresswoman contained
anecdotal reports unverified by the FDA
clinical trials have shown the vaccine
can have mild side effects and a handful
of serious side effects that are much
rarer Ms Green originally posted a
message on both platforms pointing to a
large number of reports of injury or
death among coveted vaccine recipients
as evidence that the federal government
was ignoring high amounts of coveted
vaccine deaths this has become you know
a favorite among the anti-vaxx people
now
um I'm really obviously she deserves to
be banned the band from Twitter is
permanent the band from Facebook is
temporary
I'm conflicted only in the sense that
these bands are correct but immediately
used to the advantage of these
individuals and we can't really do
anything about that I mean when people
misunderstand what free speech is when
people misunderstand what censorship is
when people claim to hold values of
businesses being able to do what's best
for them until it conflicts with what is
convenient for them
um we can't really do anything about the
fact that people like Marjorie Taylor
green will weaponize these bands but now
comes the onslaught of the right-wing
pundits confusing the Constitution with
the terms of service of a private
company
um here comes the martyrdom and the
entire thing will she say this violates
HIPAA I don't think so she's known for
talking about HIPAA but I don't think
she will actually pull that here but
this all plays into the narrative and
for all we know some of these people
maybe Marjorie Taylor green are
deliberately breaching what at this
point they have to know are the terms of
service of these companies in order to
get banned in order to claim that they
are being censored to their base so that
they will raise money it is after all an
election year now in 2022. obviously
Marjorie Taylor green and her ill could
deserve to be banned from these
platforms I'm not contesting that at all
but they have started to use these bands
almost like purple hearts in the culture
War she was banned from Twitter she it's
the equivalent of I went and I fought
for my country in this case her side by
tweeting disinformation and they Banned
Me and the ban is held up almost like a
Purple Heart metal in their mind they
love being what they call persecuted and
they immediately start fundraising off
of it and it is after all
10 months until Marjorie Green's
Marjorie Taylor Green's re-election
election and
um it is
I I I'm not saying don't ban them I'm
merely reminding everybody about the
ways in which they will immediately try
to benefit from those bans and Marjorie
Taylor green I mean in all likelihood is
going to sail to to re-election easily
we'll look at some of those poll numbers
for her on Friday uh it's not going to
make a difference in that sense but they
see these as worthy injuries sustained
in fighting the culture war that they
have created one other really funny
thing is Facebook has been like a
primary source of not I don't want to
say Source Facebook has been a primary
disseminator of covet disinformation by
allowing so much of it over the last
year and a half and it's funny that now
all of a sudden they're banning Marjory
Taylor green uh for for exactly that
reason but uh they did ban her it's
temporary she'll be back on but I expect
the fundraising emails to go out very
very soon saying they banned me give me
money so I can fight for you and medical
freedom and all this different stuff
here's something really interesting this
is sort of related to the Marjorie
Taylor green Twitter and Facebook ban
um about
was it like a month ago three weeks ago
something like that I played a video
clip for you of Republican Congressman
Dan Crenshaw who is a trump guy there's
no doubt about it Dan Crenshaw is a
trump guy criticizing the so-called
Freedom caucus of the House of
Representatives which is a very trumpy
caucus saying these people are
performance artists and they are not at
the end of the of the day really the
people that voted in support of what
Donald Trump wanted this conflict
between Crenshaw and people like
Marjorie Taylor green is now like two
trains barreling towards each other
because after this ban stunt from
Marjorie Taylor green and by stunt I
mean how she reacted to it uh Dan
Crenshaw has much more directly attacked
her and Marjorie Taylor green has now
turned on him so let me kind of explain
it all to you in the immediate hold on
let me get this all looking correct here
in the immediate aftermath of her being
banned
Dan Crenshaw posted that Marjorie
scoffed at the notion of supporting
anti-censorship legislation is
indicative of her true intent to remain
a victim she doesn't want Solutions and
she doesn't care if you get censored she
just wants to be a victim so she can
keep asking you for campaign donations
it's a scam Dan Crenshaw is a hundred
and ten percent correct here he's 110
correct Now understand that what he was
advocating for was
seriously heavy regulation of platforms
like Twitter and Facebook so he is a
hypocrite in the sense that he is part
of the party that says we should do as
little regulation of business as
possible
uh regulating businesses socialism he's
talked on the Joe Rogan show about his
belief about what socialism is and it's
a very very wrong belief so he was
ignoring his so supposedly sincerely
held beliefs about a light government
regulatory touch saying let's regulate
these companies but he is correctly
pointing out
that Marjorie Taylor green had the
opportunity to support anti-censorship
as they call it legislation and that
what she is doing is a scam to raise
campaign contributions he's completely
right he also posted I think this is on
his Instagram hey by the way Marjorie
isn't this you this was the moment you
went for a few drinks instead of voting
on The ndaa before bringing up missed
votes you might want to check your own
record this is after Marjorie Taylor
green said to Dan Crenshaw hey you've
missed votes as well this is a picture
of Marjorie Taylor green sitting at a
bar when apparently voting was taking
place on ndaa the substance of this
matter is less than the fact that two
pro-trump Republicans that's what they
are are fighting with each other
Crenshaw went on to say hey Marjorie if
suggesting we should Paul follow Trump
policy instead of Biden mandates makes
you mad then you might be a Democrat or
just an idiot so very big attacks Trump
on Trump violence Crenshaw then posted
guess some people woke up today and
tried to compete for biggest idiot on
the internet
uh then going on to say seeing a lot of
manufactured outrage by some people
lately they're worried they're losing
their grip on your attention because
they are they lash out in the hopes
you'll pay attention to them kind of sad
really
Dan Crenshaw is a totally right here
about what Marjorie Taylor green is
doing these are what we call what I call
asbs attention seeking behaviors and
Crenshaw went on to say and Marjorie
instead of playing the victim about
censorship maybe use your position as a
legislator to help pass legislation
against censorship luckily I've already
done all the hard work for you and
drafted a bill that would change section
230 to prohibit political censorship
wanna co-sponsor before I introduce it
or do you prefer to keep up with Petty
and childish attacks your call
um Marjorie Taylor green
completely then losing it on Dan
Crenshaw saying Dan Crenshaw is posting
creepy stalking pictures of me referring
to the picture from the bar
and harassing me to co-sponsor his big
Tech bill that he says stop censorship
but his bill actually gives more
protection to online porn companies very
very weird thing to post and then lastly
She Wrote
uh no thanks Dan we need to get rid of
porn I am busy reading other Republicans
stop big Tech censorship bills gosh and
to think all of this started when I just
disagreed with him when he said FEMA
should be doing Mass covet testing and
working in hospitals all I said was no
we don't want FEMA doing any of that and
hospitals need to hire back unvaccinated
health care workers then poof I'm kicked
off Twitter did I offend Dan's globalist
friends at the world economic forum
um this is this is really great I have
to tell you guys I wish that the left
was was more competently preparing for
uh 2022 and 2024. uh I think the left
may be heading for a disaster but
trumpists fighting with trumpists is a
really really good thing and just to
remind everybody here's that original
clip where Dan Crenshaw seemed to start
expressing some disdain for the grifters
like Marjorie Taylor green and others
without naming them directly remember
this
too there's actually other veterans in
Morgan's race
there's other Front Runners but why
support these two well because I've been
in Congress for almost three years now
two types of members in Congress right
there's performance artists and there's
legislators now the performance artists
are the ones that get all the attention
are the ones you think are more
conservative because they know how to
say slogans real well they know how to
recite the lines that they know that our
voters want to hear
in the first two years of Trump's
presidency when Republicans were in
control when every single time we were
voting on Donald Trump's agenda what do
you think was at the top of that list
voting with Trump and who do you think
was at the bottom yeah
a lot of names you would recognize were
at the bottom of that list a lot of
names you would recognize are at the top
of that list
number two is probably going to make you
cringe a little bit it's Adam kinsinger
Odo and Trump almost 99 he was number
two so the important thing the important
takeaway here is that these are all
trumpists in some sense marginally
Marjorie Taylor green is a trumpist in
the way that she has completely
abandoned even talking about policy
spreads lies disinformation it's kind of
like the cartoonish weaponized trumpist
but what Dan Crenshaw reminds us is that
a lot of the people that we on the left
might say they're not that bad Liz
Cheney wow she said Biden really won
that's that's really great Adam
kinzinger hey he was willing to vote to
convict Trump on impeachment uh I'm
sorry to uh he he was willing to support
impeachment of Donald Trump uh he's a
member of the house not the Senate uh
and we say wow these people are kind of
more reasonable they vote with Trump all
the time all the time and so they are
not our political allies Dan Crenshaw is
absolutely right let's hope that this
Trump on Trump Civil War continues
because the left needs something to help
us along this year
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so I have
not talked about the AOC Miami trip
because quite frankly I find it all
pretty pretty uninteresting but a bunch
of you have asked me to comment on the
coverage of it and I do think there are
a couple of interesting things there so
the back story on this as I understand
it and again I care so little about it
that I'm more interested in the reaction
than the story as I understand it over
the New Year's weekend
democratic congresswoman Alexandria
ocasio-cortez and her her partner her
boyfriend her husband I don't know the
guy the guy she's with they went down to
Miami I think she has family there
um and she was photographed
eating Outdoors without a mask
some right-wing commenters focused on
the fact that she went she escaped
liberal New York and DC to go to
conservative Florida okay not a super
interesting analysis I mean Miami is
like the most left place in Florida I
love Miami myself I would never live in
the conservative parts of Florida but I
love Miami I love the food I love the
weather I love the diversity of people
and and you know speaking Spanish with
all the Cuban Americans that are down
there you know are lots of argentinians
I don't know that it's any big
indictment on conservatism on a
liberalism that you go to Miami it's one
of the most liberal places especially
Eastern Miami-Dade County uh the other
some people focused on the fact that her
partner was wearing sandals and you
could see his feet it was very very
strange and then AOC shot back a lot of
these people that are mad they actually
they actually want to date me which I
thought it was a little bit weird a
little bit pompous and presumptuous but
I just don't really care about it but a
very interesting thing happened which is
that on Fox news reporter Charlie
gasparino actually said to be honest
with you
the criticism AOC is getting is unfair
and the anchor didn't like it and
started arguing with Charlie gasparino
who was just very honest take a look at
this
the entire segment is called rules for
thee not for me by the way and AOC was
eating outside without a mask I mean
that's allowed everywhere I don't even
know what what is unfair about that
well it seems like
when in Miami at least she's sitting
outside but what does that mean she's
okay what are you talking about
now there's video of her outside hugging
someone
partying up dropping the cover while
partying at that crowded bar there in
Florida critics are calling her a
hypocrite as covid cases spiked back in
her home state of New York Charlie and
by the way cases are spiking in Florida
too it's not but hospitalizations are up
200 percent like even the whole framing
is crazy but let's get into the meat
spirino joins us now so Charlie is it
fair that many are calling her out for
being a hypocrite while parting it up in
Florida while her home state is battling
a record covet surge
uh be honest with you
no I I yeah it is unfair I I don't I
don't see why why she can't go to
Florida and have a good time I mean I
kind of wish I was nobody said she can't
I was I was included questions
so what exactly is the hypocrisy is it
she wasn't wearing a mask outside
because
basically no one is is it that she went
to a different what is the hypocrisy
exactly
um listen it's Epoch it's it's a it's a
it's a hypocrisy if she's sitting around
talking about what a bad job DeSantis is
doing the governor DeSantis of Florida
is doing as opposed to what a great job
uh governor hokel in New York is doing
then it would be hypocritical for her to
go and party in the place uh in the
center of of evil let me make this a
little Charlie sheets
the anchor does not like that Charlie
gasparino is off message here
Charlie she's been very supportive of a
very strict measures in her home state
to fight the coronavirus pandemic
Florida many Democrats have been very
critical of Florida that has been more
relaxed on some of those measures she is
choosing to vacation there and live it
up without her mask on and kiss and hug
this this is a Fox News Alert I am going
to support AOC on this here's why she
was outside I mean I don't think she's
unless you could show me you know some
some Tweeter some Pub some statement
from her saying I think people even
outside when they go jogging when they
eat outside should have face masks on
then it's not hypocritical because she's
outside and and by the way you can be
critical of Florida in terms of its lack
of access to testing because you would
like to see schools take some
if you go to Miami and sit outside at a
restaurant you're not really being
hypocritical I mean it's just it's what
what was incredible was the degree to
which this was Story number one on Fox
News I mean look look at some of the
coverage of this Alexandria
ocasio-cortez accused of hypocrisy
Alexandria ocasio-cortez of hypocrisy
rules for thee but not for me AOC AOC
AOC maybe AOC needs to go back to the
Border Alexandria ocasio-cortez
Alexandria ocasio-cortez Alexandria
kazia Cortez Alexandria ocasio-cortez
Alexandria ocasio-cortez Alexandria
ocasio-cortez Alexandria ocasio-cortez
the heat AOC is getting by the way this
is all within a seven hour period Casio
Cortez the so-called Squad member
furthermore I want to talk about AOC
Alexandria ocasio-cortez
Republicans were like hot for her body
Brian The Motley Crue song right the
girl don't go away man just go away
don't come down here why are you coming
down here AOC says that you just start
you just are sexually frustrated you
want to date her that you want to date
Communists so tell me about that she
says they're mad because they can't date
her Sean Duffy now I do I do admit that
they're mad because they can't date her
it comes off as a little bit arrogant
it's probably true with some of them by
the way it's probably but it's not the
type of thing you're supposed to say so
another fabricated story
um and again I do think Charlie
gasparino is right if she was uh indoors
at some big concert with no mask I think
it would be different but many of us all
along have been saying there should be
testing we're fine with vaccine mandates
you should wear masks and doors
but no one's really getting this
outdoors and sitting outdoors and in
fact going to a warm place and where
it's easier to sit Outdoors seems like a
completely coherent thing to do given
that belief I'm not even a big defender
of AOC but this was very very stupid all
right I have something for you today
that I think some of you are going to
think is funny
but it's really not it's actually really
really horrifying
um I don't know how many of you remember
this guy Stu Peters we're going to look
back at in a bit we're going to look
back at a clip from a couple weeks ago
where Stu Peters said he believes that
the flu or covid that he got
was given to him deliberately like a
weapon and he said that without any
evidence he interviewed yesterday an
anti-vaccine actress known as Crystal
teeny
that's Crystal teeny
who
I I there's no way for me to say this
without just saying what it is she
claims that when she's near vaccinated
people she has anal bleeding
okay
um
she she believes that that symptom is
being caused by people shedding the
vaccine onto her that it causes anal
bleeding
um she's a dancer model choreographer
type person hair stylist I think
um she has hair accessories and makes
yoga elements and she is anti-vaxx take
a listen to what she had to say listen
carefully because she uses coded
language insanely alarming plots
yes
okay yeah well that is absolutely
alarming have you visited with a doctor
a physician
um and and talked about this or I mean
are you pretty much have you made up in
your own mind that if you were to go
speak to a doctor that they would tell
you that you're nuts that this just
doesn't happen that this doesn't exist
despite the fact that it's proven that
it does exist several experts have said
that is that why you're hesitant to go
or have you gone I have not I have not
gone and people I found like maybe you
should go to the doctor but I know
exactly what they're going to say and
especially because I am not vaccinated
they're going to say that is no relation
and I'm not going to waste my time doing
that after all the research that I've
done and I know that you have done uh we
do know that there is a relation to it
and I I actually did a video like way
back when in the very beginning when
people started getting vaccinated
noticing problems with their menstrual
cycles and things like that now for me
obviously there are people getting
nosebleeds anal bleeding and vaginal
bleeding I will do the process of
elimination I am not vaginally bleeding
or bleeding from the nose so okay so
understand what she says she says some
people are getting nosebleeds vaginal
bleeding or anal bleeding I'm not
getting vaginal and I'm not getting nose
bleeding so she's saying I'm getting
anal bleeding when I'm near vaccinated
people
the fact that it is something more
serious since obviously women menstruate
and
um it's really really scary so I'm not
going to go to a doctor it does resolve
over a period of time it's been almost a
week and I am still experiencing the
symptoms so guys
if she I'm not joking around here if
she's telling the truth this could be
colon cancer
it could be a bunch of other things
it's I if she's just lying and saying
being near she's not even saying these
are side effects from getting vaccinated
she's saying these are side effects from
being near vaccinated people when she
goes near a vaccinated person she has
anal bleeding for a week and then it
resolves she says if she's lying then
it's crazy
if she's telling the truth she really
needs to be evaluated I mean I'm I'm not
kidding around and this is maybe the
craziest show I've ever seen this is a
reminder of when Stu Peters claimed that
someone infected him deliberately with
the virus as opposed to like he just
caught it that wouldn't be surprised if
this so-called cold the virus the flu
that I have right now was a targeted
attack on media do you speculate that
some of that might be going on as well
right a targeted attack yeah I mean
absolutely like the bio weapon being
released on you this the sociopath Tony
fauci when he chimerically engineered
this taxpayer-funded lab originated
intentionally released Wuhan China virus
and I should make clear just so we don't
get any in any trouble on YouTube the
claims being made right now by Stu
Peters are untrue I mean that could
probably be used against people
automatically I mean people Republicans
conservatives talk show host people
being targeted with this virus anyway
you guys get it he he caught a virus
against which he was not vaccinated and
he's says it must have been a targeted
attack really scary stuff if these
people really believe this stuff then
they do need to be medically evaluated
if they are just lying then it's
extremely immoral what they are doing we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P
this caller asks a good question which
is
would Joe Rogan ever have me back on his
show given that I have been critical of
him about this statements about covet
and the pandemic take a listen
change
hey David uh this is Anthony from New
Jersey I just listened to your uh
podcast today and uh you've played that
clip with Rogan interviewing the guy who
claims he invented uh
I'm RNA vaccines
um I was just wondering is there a
chance that you're ever going to go on
Rogan or have Rogan come on your show so
you could just call him out on his
nonsense I mean he just sit there like
like an idiot like a pump on a lot while
these guys just spew out garbage and he
doesn't even do anything
to
you know form a referral it almost seems
like he agrees with it half the time we
need somebody a man of your caliber to
go on there and tell this stoned idiot
you know that he needs to wake up well
listen I don't know that we need the ad
hominems I know that there are other
people in my space who have opted not to
critique the things Joe Rogan has said
and some of them privately will message
me and say that critique you did of Joe
Rogan was really good
um I don't know why that's their choice
I know that to some degree with someone
with such a big show as Rogan you want
to maintain the possibility at least of
being invited on
um it would be very notable if I was not
criticizing the things Rogan was saying
because I'm obviously aware aware of
them I've been on his show a couple of
times as I've said before I have no idea
if Rogan is even aware of the things I
have said about his coverage uh if he is
he may be very willing to talk to me and
we would just have adult conversations
about these things and I would tell them
the same thing to his face that I say on
the show it's not a big deal I'm
comfortable disagreeing with people it's
not it's not a big deal he may be mad in
some way or you know have written me off
or he may have no idea whatsoever I am
glad to go back absolutely anytime uh
okay on the bonus show today I will
explain many of you noticing that I do
have a Band-Aid on my finger uh it is
actually quite a story what happened I
am gonna explain that on today's bonus
show we're going to talk about TED
Cruz's impeachment promise
uh you can probably guess what it is and
we will also talk about
fluorona fluorona has been detected a
combination flu coronavirus diagnosis
all of those stories and more will be on
today's bonus show access the bonus show
by signing up at joinpakman.com you can
use the coupon code wow22.
you have to say it that way when you
type it in WoW 22 wow 2-2 you will save
big and we'll see you on today's bonus
show
magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code Pacman